i am
i've heard a demonstration in scotland
once many years ago
and
i was doing my opinion
trying them and of course you go like
this and someone in the audience said of
course he can do it look at the size of
his hands
it took about 20 years to lose
strength
because i you don't you don't know what
your own strength is you know even the
smallest person
on the mat here today you you can't feel
your strength
you can figure your determination you
can increase that or or not but
uh yeah
if i try to go into these two guys here
what i'd like to do just come in a
little bit
look at my arm
think of a bokken upside down
i can't go into them
it says he used to tip the top
of the bottom
and he'd wind it
down
much about
yeah this is even better because now
nick's decided to lock my elbow
but that's good because it means the tip
of the bottom's here isn't it
so
i mean it's taken all these years to
learn that so you're not going to get
any
but we were on the wrong end
that's what i'm saying you know so since
he would say he would do this and he'd
push and he would be exaggerated with
facial expressions and that and then you
just get one thing would do like this
with the bottom and throw the person
down
so i know i tell you every time
but the last place
i go is into them
but in a normal uh
coco that's what you see you see
you see that happening
you see him going in
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go over
to jenny
but you won't see it because i can't go
there can i but this shoulder
softens and it relaxes towards jenny
i don't turn this because if i turn it
then i'm going to have to go back to get
in
so i can't show this side
so what i do is i'm i soften that
shoulder towards jenny
they can feel it draining away from them
their grip their hold so i'm still going
to jenny but at a certain point when my
elbow's low enough
i can go in
so now they've got this weight down here
so there's no point going into it
i haven't got this foot so i can get
that
so i'm doing everything except what it
looks like
and i've made a video at some stage
saying if we could blend
iwama
aikido
with aikikai
we'd to me we'd have the most perfect
art because there's fluidity
in the aikikai style but he's beautiful
to me that
that little sliver that someone got
if we can put that
back in the cake
then we should have everything we should
have confidence to be able to overcome
strength
and we should have fluidity
cytosense he told me off because i'd
done an interview with sam cranny
and said trouble this is like it doesn't
have any fluidity
and he said
what's wrong
what's wrong with the fluid
it's just because you can't see it from
the outside
i mean to say it's not happening on the
the technique because you're using parts
of your body
your other body or something
so enough said i'd like you to go into
threes
and do this
don't pick these two they're weak